c'est la championne cliqueter la
championne clé c'est la championne
slicks et la championne slip et la
championne ce flic c'est la championne
s'est tout de suite au karaoké des
remarques c'est parti d'une gare
géomètre une musique qui vraiment kivu
symbolise que vous aimez la musique qui
me que j'aime bien c'est pas brillante
c'est ça oui je n'aime pas les
protocoles
est-ce que ça c'est si je n'aime pas le
monde m'a pas pourquoi on a choisi on a
choisi soprano enfin
[Musique]
et en fait tu es en fait tu es en feu ni
d'un blanc là je suis en veux tu en veux
je suis enfin caroline
on a choisi pour une chanson de mylène
farmer je suis libertine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
matt pokora
cette année l'armée ont tiré mon on a
choisi un match d'équipé labeaume
c'est la championne cliqueter la
championne des championnes flic c'est la
championne slicks et la chanteraine ce
flic c'est la championne slip la
championne smic c'est la championne si
je gardais on a choisi allumé l'os audio
diadie des allumés allumez le feu allumé
hello feux allumés
[Musique]
seul
quelques heures
pour moi
si slimane panama
on arrive moi ma gueule et monstres
gâteau padam padam
paname on arrive là et mon sac cadeau
paname paname on arrive ma nana na na na
na on appris ce jour donc vous adorez
attend samir j'ai cherché
de là
je ne sais pas du tout la chanson you ou
mais je viens faire ramener ses jours
ça
c'était la plus simple un nul 0 washing
[Musique]